hello everyone as you've heard in my
previous video I will be visiting bad
pavement in Germany from 12 to 19th of
January so unfortunately I will not be
able to cover the first five or six
rounds of the Tata Steel chess
tournament I will cover them eventually
when I get back but I will not be able
to cover them in real time as I usually
do so feel free to post your suggestions
in the comments below I will read all
the comments as always and if there's a
nice game that was played in the first
couple of rounds I will cover it on my
channel so that's one thing I wanted to
say and the other thing is after I get
back from Germany I will also start be
streaming on Twitch so far I've only
been streaming and YouTube but now I
will also use twitch so in the
description below there will be a link
to my twitch channel feel free to check
it out and follow that channel as well
so you get notified when I start the
streams there's still nothing there
since I haven't used it I only uploaded
two videos so it wouldn't be empty but
yeah if that's something you're
interested in feel free to follow that
channel as well so this game here
morphia is playing against Cheryl
d'amour II own a child amore owned is
Murphy's childhood friend they been
together quite a lot they went to school
together both Murphy's father and the
mauryans father are both lawyers and
Cheryl here is the only person to ever
receive HS lessons from morphe himself
so quite he know quite a lucky guy I
guess and I wouldn't usually cover a
game where one player is giving odds of
a rook and the knight but this game is
such a brilliancy and the game would be
completely the same even if morphe had
all of the pieces which is which is
exactly why the game is instructed how
not to be materialistic in chess and how
not to play chess in general so let's
see this game it was played in 1854 in
New Orleans and morphe opens with efore
i will not be naming any opening since
morphe is playing with so much odds
there really is no point in naming
openings here ecigs by Shara a 4d v & E
5 morphic closes up the
as he's done to pieces there's a really
no point in exchanging even more
material Knight to e7
we have Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
the g4 Murphy goes goes for it as he
does have to finish it up Bishop to e7
we have d4 sharp castles and c3 now
adding more protection to the d4 pawn so
now the pieces can move f5 by charl and
now it captures on f6 and pass on Bishop
captures and h4 by Murphy and here this
is a good moment to really check out
what's going on morph is obviously
preparing g5 h5 some ideas after g5 is
pushed may be nice the e5 Queen to h5
definitely will be an idea and in this
position sharp plays Knight to a5 and
this move doesn't really have anything
to do with what morphe is doing them the
board I mean black is off to pieces he
can play pretty much anything he can
push he 5 and for example if F
characters on e5 simply Bishop
characters on g4 if pawn captures Queen
can capture this pawn this night is now
attacked three times and you're getting
your piece back but I mean it's not like
you need pieces you're up so much
material but okay after h4 our our plays
Knight to a5 we have g5 attacking the
bishop Bishop to e7 and h5 now Knights
the d7 by Sheryl Bishop to d3 and here
char plays Knight to b6 and more figures
Queen to c2 and morphe is still down to
pieces but if you look at blacks pieces
for example this knight on a five and
nine b6 it really doesn't have anything
to do with what morphe is doing and on
the King side here so not not definitely
not the way to develop your pieces and
this is already a critical position
morphe is threatening to capture on h7
and you do have to you know make
something happen here what's the idea
well since you are off to pieces you
could try for example to escape with
your king but this doesn't work this
looses immediately after Knight to e5
you have to go back and face
captures on h7 or you go to e8 and then
Vishal comes to g6 and it's game over
pawn captures Queen captures rogue
blocks and Queen captures on f7 this is
checkmate another thing you can try
after Queen to c2 is maybe rook to f7 so
now you try to escape this way but now
g6 comes and after H captures H captures
you don't really have a good Square for
the rook if you play something like rook
to f6 or f5 then rook to h8 leads the
checkmate but maybe you can try rook to
f8 but still this leads to checkmate
although it's a quite quite a long
checkmate it's still checkmate it's a
rope to h8 check and after King captures
Queen to h2 check bishop has the block
if you go King GA 2 then Queen to h7 is
checkmate so bishop has the block and
now Knight captures so again the thread
is the Knight to f5 discovered check and
then Queen comes to h7 this is checkmate
so you do have to block this for example
rook to f6 make an escape route for the
king and after Knight to f5 check King
to g8 Queen to h7 check King f8 Queen
captures King te8 now comes Queen to h8
check King tries to escape and now comes
this very nice move Bishop to b5 check
you've logged this with c6
but now the King doesn't have the c6
square for escape so now Queen to h7
check King has to go back and now g7
threatening pond to g8 with to bring
another Queen into the game so black has
to stop this he has to give up a rock
and I'll simply you capture at King
captures Queen to g7 check King e8
quinta g8 check King to d7 and Queen to
f7 followed by Queen D queenie 87 and
Queen captures on e7 and this is
checkmate so this is quite a long
checkmate
it's actually 27 moves but after rook to
f7 you know it's pretty much forced so
after Queen to c2 and none of these
moves are actually good here sharra
played h6
which is a really terrible move but one
move that he I don't know if he didn't
consider
or he thought h6 would maybe be fine is
actually rook to f5 and after up to f5
you pretty much stop every plan more if
he had you completely block this if more
if he pushes anything you just block the
position if more if he ever captures the
rook then he captures on f5 and mostly
simply doesn't have enough pieces to
continue the attack so you know if
you're already you're never gonna be up
two pieces from the start of the game
but maybe you will win a piece in the
middle of the game and then maybe you
know if you can't defend you have to
give something back and then you will be
able to defend this is something
probably
Shaul learned after this game but okay
after Queen to c2
he played h6 now G characters on h6 was
played G Catherine's on h6 and crook to
g1 would check King to h8 was played if
you play King to f7 this is also a very
nice variation then comes a bishop to g6
King to f6 and now Bishop - eh
threatening Queen to g6 checkmate so
this has to be stopped
Bishop to d6 making an escape route for
the King but now comes Queen to h7 not
allowing the King to escape Queen
captures Bishop and now Queen to g7
check King has to move and now it's a I
mean so far it was everything for us but
now it's nice to h4 check King has to go
deeper Queen G to check King King can't
go back because the f5 square is now
covered by the by the knight King to d3
and now comes Queen to e2 and this is
checkmate
so after rope to g1 King to f7 is a
no-go so King to h8 was played here rook
to g6 by morphine
we have rope to f6 protecting the h6
pawn queen to g2 we have Queen to f8 and
now nice to h4 adding more protection to
the rook Queen to f7 and now comes f5
also adding more protection to the rug
but also now the bishop can capture on
h6 and here at Bishop to d7 was played
by Charl
preparing this rook to come help help
out with the defense instead of Bishop
d7 you
consider a move like rook captures on G
on g6 but then after Knight captures
this is with check a kink has to move
and now for example Knight captures you
can't recapture because now f6 will
result in losing a queen there's the
discovered check from the bishop here oh
okay after f5 he played Bishop to d7
preparing to bring the other rook into
the game and Bishop captures and h6 was
played by morphe rook to g8
and now Bishop to g5 we have rook
captures Knight captures with check rook
captures and now H captures on g6 and
this comes with an attack on the Queen
Queen to g7 and now morphic plays Queen
to h1 check you don't really have any
options here other than play King to g8
so King to g8 and here morphe played f6
and in this position shot the Mauryan
resigned the game and it's very
interesting why did he resign the game
well ok let's check out one variation if
you play king - Queen to h8 to get the
Queen out of the way simply f7 check
King has to move it and now you simply
capture the Queen Queen captures would
check King captures and now Bishop
captures on e7 and there is no way to
stop promotion of this pawn the knight
can't help out since the bishop is
blocking so this is one way to do it on
the other hand after this f6 move what
happens if Bishop captures pawn if
Bishop captures pawn and Bishop captures
Queen captures and queen to h7 after
King to f8 it doesn't seem like there is
a way to continue this attack you can
push g7 Queen simply captures you can
check the black King anywhere so what do
you do here sorry
now you can't even capture the bishop as
the knight is guarding it so what's the
idea here that Charlotte Amorian
resigned the game for no reason well not
really after f6 there is actually a
brilliant way to end the game if Bishop
captures and f6 was played and here you
know feel free to pause the video and
find it you know we will feel very good
about yourself if you solve this
position so I will give it a couple of
seconds if you want to check it out so
okay for those of you who managed to
find the solution to this great position
congratulations for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show the move you
have to find is actually Queen to h7 and
this is which check so what happens here
if you play King to f8 then Bishop to h6
you lose the Queen and the game if on
the other hand you don't if you decide
to capture the Queen then after Queen
captures now you capture G characters on
h7 this is what check and the pawn is
protected so the King has to move if you
play King to h8 now Bishop captures on
f6 is checkmate King has nowhere to go
and if you don't if you play something
like King the g7 to still protect the
Queen square again a bunch of characters
on f7 you can't capture the pawn you can
go to h8 you can go to g8 so simply
capture the bishop and now h8 with Queen
this comes with check and White is
simply now some white is simply up
material and winning the game
so after this f6 move it it's hard to
say if Sheryl the Mauryan here figured
out all of these variations or did did
maybe he just had enough of morphia
having his way with him but either way
quite a quite a spectacular game by
morphe and really showing us haha how
chest should be played so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Norman Hardin and Gregory
graph instead for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon